Grand Admiral Thrawn is missing
from your delegation.
Any word on when he will be able
to participate in the Shadow Council?
You have spoken of his imminent return.
Welcome back, everyone, it's Charlie.
This is the way.
This will be my Four Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 7 Video
There were so many Easter eggs
and references paying off so many long
running plots and setting stuff up
for Ahsoka with Grand Admiral Thrawn.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I just did a trailer video for Ahsoka
with Grand Admiral Thrawn
and we finally saw him on screen,
so I'll talk about him during the video
when we get to that part of the plot.
But careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet.
Let's just start at the beginning.
Work our way through, shot by shot,
Talking about Easter eggs in WTF moments,
starting with the episode title The Spies.
It was a reference to what Elliott Cain
was doing on Khorasan.
She was spying for Moff Gideon,
informing him on what was going on
with the New Republic
so that the Shadow Council could maneuver
around them as part of this grand plan.
The plan that Grand Admiral Thrawn
is orchestrating his heir
to the Empire and retaking the galaxy
from the New Republic.
The actual opening scene
starts on Coruscant in the lower levels
with Elliott Cain
going to a secret meeting
to get more orders from Moff
Gideon in the Imperial Remnant, the Shadow
Council confirming a lot of our theories
about what
she's been doing this whole time,
how Moff Gideon
has been behind her actions.
She talks to an Imperial probe droid
like the ones they see
in all the movies in the series.
They use probe droids a lot of the time,
she informs Moff Gideon, who's
talking to her via hello from his base.
But the Armor's mandalorians defeating
Gordian Shards Pirates on Navarro.
Notice how he asks
which group of Mandalorians helped them
because he was personally behind
the Great Purge and scattering
all the remaining Mandalorians
and he controls Mandalore currently,
so he wants to know which faction
has moved against them.
Also,
when he says which group of mandalorians
that's meant to Senate the concept
of the Mandalorian Super commandos
that he has in the Pretorian Guard
working for the Empire,
the Imperial Remnant.
Like there's a faction that is now
working for him, the former Mol DeLorean,
the former members of Death
Watch the Armor said,
scattered and broken to different
factions themselves during the episode.
They also confirm
what happened to Deathwatch
after the Clone Wars
and how they scattered to different
factions basically in their group.
Now, the Armor's group formed out of that
and they call themselves
the children of the Watch.
I think that's meant to set up the idea
that some of those former death watch
that became more delorean's
and then became Mandalorian
Super Commandos working for the Empire.
And then they started working for Moff
Gideon after Return of the Jedi.
So the whole idea is that not all
Mandalorian factions are meant to be good.
It's just foreshadowing
for the end of the episode
when they reveal that group
of super commandos leftover from Clone
Wars and Star Wars rebels and Moff Gideon
basically answers all of our theories
about his grand plan
and his specific plans
and how they're different from Grand
Admiral Thrawn Grand plan,
Lots of grand planning, grand people
in the Star Wars universe right now.
But the whole idea is that Moff
Gideon has had her running interference
against the New Republic inside
that requisition office, doing everything
she could to keep them
from getting involved in the outer rim,
allowing his faction
the empire, or at least in different parts
of the galaxy, to rise without having
to worry about the New Republic,
finding out what they're doing.
It sounds like she's
been very successful in that.
Like we saw when Carson Thibeault
was denied help from Colonel Tuttle.
It sounds like she's been doing that
for a long time now.
Moff Gideon has also been counting
on The Mandalorian factions to continue
being at odds with each other to prevent
exactly from what happened
during this episode. Bo-Katan
beginning to regain her
former military strength
by uniting them together.
Which is why initially
he doesn't believe he can Like, no way.
There's no way
they would all come together.
They all hate each other.
Then they jump to Moff Gideon
side of the transmission.
And if it wasn't clear, the whole idea
during
the episode is they wanted to reveal
that Moff Gideon had been on the Mandalore
planet near the Great Forge with this base
this whole time.
So it's like that call is coming
from inside the room kind of thing.
Like he'd been transmitting in this base
here, talking to the other shadow
council, orchestrating his whole operation
from the planet Mandalore.
He walks past
the Imperial Super Commandos,
which he controls past more tanks,
a failed clone experiments.
They also clarify some of our theories
about what's going on with all the Grogu
cloning plot.
And it turns out
there are a couple different plans
at play here as the Shadow Council starts
arguing with each other,
each one having a different idea
about what
they should be doing with their resources.
All explain that in the second.
But his cloning takes like his specific
cloning experiments are a callback
to the Mandalorian Season two.
In all of Dr.
Pershing's grogu cloning experiments,
he walks into a meeting with almost
the entire Imperial remnant forces,
with all the admirals, generals, captains,
like all the leaders who are acting
as warlords, controlling different sectors
of the galaxy, like the Imperial
Remnant, has basically divided
the galaxy up into different sectors.
So that's why we haven't seen every single
one of them up to this point.
These past couple seasons,
the show has mostly been localized
to very specific parts of the galaxy,
really good example of them
exploring different parts of the galaxy
is the Star Wars Skeleton Crew series
That's going to visit
a completely different part,
and they'll probably run into one of the
other factions of this Imperial remnant.
Here's the thing, though
They actually didn't explain who
every single
one of these Imperial warlords is.
Only a couple of them,
but the ones that they do reveal are huge
deep cut Easter eggs for big storylines,
particularly for the grand Admiral Thrawn
original trilogy,
The Heir to the Empire movie
that they're setting up the big crossover.
The person who's speaking
when he walks in is Xander Berkley,
who's playing Gilad Pellaeon.
You might recognize him from other series,
but Pellaeon is from
the original Thrawn trilogy.
He's meant to be his right hand man,
which is why during his speech
when he's talking, he keeps referencing
grand Admiral Thrawn's return.
We have to wait for his return.
Grand Admiral Throne's return will herald
in the reemergence of our military
like they're planning on a giant strike,
like actually launching an all out war
against the New Republic once
grand Admiral Thrawn arrives,
who we just saw in the Ahsoka
trailer played by Lars Mikkelsen,
who also voiced the character on Star Wars
Rebels.
I cannot wait to see him on Ahsoka because
next week is The Mandalorian Season
three finale Episode eight.
We might get a teaser for him
at the end of that episode.
Most of you probably remember him
from the Sherlock series.
With Benedict Cumberbatch,
everything is available for a price.
You make me an offer, a Christmas Present.
Then what are you giving me for
Christmas? Mr. Holmes?
I will start my operations here
and for the rebels about piece by piece.
They will be the architects
of their own destruction.
The plan
is cautioning, hiding their true strength
until Thrawn returns to the new Republic,
we'll just leave them alone.
They won't find out what they're doing
until it's too late.
But he does note
how the New Republic is weak right now,
and they're gaining more and more assets.
That's a callback to this entire
New Republic storyline this season.
They've tried to drag
the New Republic under the bus.
So many episodes
they seem kind of ineffectual.
They're spinning their wheels.
They're not really doing that much.
They're also destroying
all of their military assets
like they have all these star destroyers,
all these former imperial capital ships.
They're scrapping
and they're scrapping their former
capital ships from the rebellion.
So they're trying to establish
why Grand Admiral Thrawn forces,
the Imperial remnant, would be able
to challenge them The next Imperial war.
Lord says his faction of the Imperial
Remnant
has been busy plundering hyperspace lanes
in a different sector of the galaxy,
just stealing from trade ships
that pass through.
One of the other female
admiral says that there are people
on all the planets in the galaxy
who are still loyal to the Empire.
People
kind of like Cyril Khan on the Andor
series, people who love the order
that the Empire brings, even if it's at
the cost of personal freedoms.
Another one of the leaders advocates
for a show of strength.
So it's just meant to show
how they all have
different ideas
about what they should be doing
and who's the actual captain of this ship,
so to speak.
Moff Gideon arguing
about how a new person should lead them
when really it's actually grand
Admiral Thrawn that they've been waiting
for, implying that the Imperial remnant
just in general,
all these different factions
all over the galaxy
have been looking to grant Admiral Thrawn
as their de facto leader
after the fall of the Empire
in Return of the Jedi.
But when Pullman keeps talking
about the reemergence of Granny Smith
on his return,
when is he going to show up?
Because Moff Gideon
gets kind of impatient.
Like when will Thrawn finally show up?
We've been waiting for him
this whole time, all these years.
We might get a teaser for that
during the finale, but mostly
we'll see that start to happen
during the Ahsoka series
because Ahsoka's big thing
is trying to find grand.
Admiral
Thrawn also looking for Ezra Bridger
because he was lost
with Thrawn at the same time
I started hearing whispers
about Theron's return
as heir to the Empire.
But that storyline will culminate
with a giant war
with the Imperial remnant in Thrawn.
That'll be their big heir
to the Empire movie.
My early theory right now
is that they'll call that movie
Heir to the Empire
and just based on
the original Thrawn trilogy.
But then they reveal Commandant Hux, who's
actually working on Project Necromancer.
He's meant to be the father of General Hux
during the sequel trilogy,
who would be a young kid
at this point in the timeline.
He's also played by Donal Gleeson's
real life brother, Brian Gleeson.
So a little Easter egg there,
keeping it in the family metaphorically
and literally.
But he represents the faction
that's part of the first order, implying
that the first order was in league
with the main Imperial remnant forces
the entire time.
Like they weren't
always doing their own thing.
And Project Necromancer is their project.
His goal to bring back the Empire
using the cloning technology,
which they actually started
during the bad batch episodes.
The whole Mount Tannis plot on Bad
Batch is about them trying to perfect
cloning technology to resurrect
the emperor, being able to clone a force
sensitive person, which they haven't
been able to do up to this point,
and provide Commander Hux enough time
to deliver on Project Necromancer.
But here's how we get back to the idea
that none of these Shadow
Council members agree with each other
about what they should be doing.
Moff Gideon
seems like he one that does not care
about Grand Admiral Thrawn
or bringing the Emperor back.
He complains that he's grown
tired of waiting for Thrawn.
They need to elect a new leader
for the Shadow
Council
like a de facto leader of this new empire.
And obviously he thinks it should be him.
Even though in a funny way,
Comic-Con Hunt speaks up and says,
Don't worry,
that's what Project Necromancer is for.
We're going to bring back
somebody else who's even better.
The grand Admiral Thrawn, obviously he's
talking about Emperor Palpatine.
But the funny way that Moff
Gideon reacts to this, he's like,
You know, that's nice,
but how about we do something else?
How about we not bring back the emperor?
That's actually a pretty big thing with
grand Admiral Thrawn character to Green.
Admiral Thrawn never liked the Emperor.
He actually only
pretended to submit to him and joined
the Empire as a way to protect his people.
The Yes.
That's one of the reasons
why grand Admiral
Thrawn is a much more complex
type of antagonist
in the Star Wars universe
because he's not a villain
the same way that the Emperor
was a villain.
His ultimate goal in creating order in
the galaxy was to protect his people.
Like his first loyalty was to the Kiss
race,
and everything he did
was in service of the ship's race,
even though in pursuit of that, he's
doing a lot of terrible things,
like obviously he's going to be
one of the big antagonists of this heir
to the Empire movie that they do.
So he does not want the emperor
to come back because the emperor basically
would have used up
the resources of his people
the same way that Moff Gideon is using,
that the resources of the Mandalorians
and all these
are cultures to his own ends.
Somehow Palpatine returned,
so neither Moff Gideon or Grand Admiral
Thrawn want the Emperor to come back.
But obviously
nobody told Commandant Hux about this.
Like they had this whole faction
of the first order, often
the unknown regions that are like, No, no,
no, we have to bring the emperor back.
Which is why he's complained
to Moff Gideon about not giving him
Doctor Pershing's cloning technology
and research that he found using Grogu
you implying that moff Gideon
has just been stringing him along like,
you know, we lost all that.
He got captured by the New Republic.
Maybe you'll get that research someday.
This confirms a big theory
that I've had since season one.
When they tease
that whole grogu cloning plot.
The whole idea is that Moff
Gideon wants to take the best scar
Weapons technology Beskar Steel armor
in the Grogu Cloning technology
to create force sensitive clones in Beskar
armor basically make
an invincible force of troopers.
But they also want to tease this idea
that the Pill remnant
is kind of fighting with itself
over what it should be doing next.
So he's hiding a lot of those plans
from the rest of the Shadow Council.
Remember, one of the big concepts inside
Star Wars is that evil
often defeats itself
like Darth Vader is the person
who ultimately defeated the emperor
thrown down the elevator shaft.
So don't be surprised
if something similar happens
during this big heir to the Empire
Thrawn movie that they eventually do,
culminating all these events
when Pullman references the Grand Plan.
That's Theron's grand plan.
Also, Mother,
I wink at Thrawn being a grand admiral
when Moff Gideon complains
about playing in Commandant
Hook's the first order, amassing resources
to their own end and not sharing them.
That's more of a reference
to what's going on
with the first order
During this part of the timeline.
They're located in the unknown
regions up here.
They're currently building
the Starkiller base, which obviously
they won't finish until the sequel trilogy
much later in the timeline.
That's
where all the extra resources are going.
But when Moff Gideon requests three extra
Pretorian guards, those are the same types
of pretorian guard you saw in Last Jedi
also setting up the end of the episode
when they arrive to kill Paz Vizsla.
So repeat to him.
Don't worry, we'll talk about that
when we get to that part of the episode.
The whole idea with the Pretorian guard
is that they're not meant to be force
sensitive.
They're not Sith, but they were Emperor
Palpatine's personal Royal Guard,
like his handpicked guard
of the fearsome stormtroopers
and people that he would train in all
the different martial arts of the galaxy.
Like terracotta.
They were trained in Jedi martial arts.
They were beskar armor.
They wield the most dangerous weapons,
like those stun batons
are meant to be the same kinds of stuff.
The times that are used
by general grievous guards.
You also see
those during the Last Jedi too.
So it's a good example
of how good they do against regular Jedi.
They're not meant to be former Inquisitor
Aureus or anything like that.
Like they weren't inquisitors,
they weren't force sensitive,
but they're meant to be the most hardcore
fighting group in the galaxy next
to regular Mandalorians.
Also, their weapons are best guard too,
which is why they're able to pierce
pass vizsla as beskar armor.
They also reveal here
that the tie interceptors that we saw
in episode three belong to Moff Gideon.
He's also requested more of them.
We find out what was going on
with them too.
Being stationed at Mandalore,
the planet near the Great Forge.
But he explains why it's so important
for them to stop Bo-Katan
in the mandalorians
from fully coming together
because he needs all those beskar
resources.
Obviously be good for the shadow
Council, the Imperial Remnant.
But Moff Gideon really wants this all
for his own personal gain.
The rest of the Shadow Council agrees
to give him what he asked
for, setting up the end of the episode
and they go out on their own
for the Empire,
which is meant to be sort of a darker
parallel for
this is the way where Paths Visit goes out
at the end of the episode.
Long Live the Empire, Mom
No, this is the words.
Then they jump back to Navarro,
where the townspeople
are still cleaning up the wreckage
of glory in shards power battle.
Not a lot of time has passed
since that episode.
Bo-Katan returns with Mando the Night
Owls, other ships, including Moff Gideon
Old Light Cruiser,
which now has the skull of the myth,
the sword painted on the bottom.
Also the myth.
This is the symbol of all mandalorians
in all different factions.
Regardless of their different beliefs,
they reveal the armor's group have created
an encampment in the lava flats
the group targeted to them earlier.
I'm sure given enough time,
they create more permanent homes.
The armor sees them knowing instantly
that it means bo-katan was successful
in getting the support of the night owls.
Remember,
there are only one other group of
mandalorians
even though we meet a second group
when they're on the Mandalore planet,
a smaller group
ages me to show you
that there are many other factions.
The mandalorians out there
you notice on Bo-Katan ship to Grogu,
who is now riding in her lap,
not in this little pod.
More space Mom vibes Here is just another
sign of how close Grogu feels to her.
He thinks about her the same way that he
thinks that Mando is the surrogate father.
They give you a wide shot of their fleet.
Now they've got a bunch of mandalorian
fighters like Bo-Katan Moff.
Gideon is old, like cruiser,
at least two Imperial transport ships
like they stole during season two.
It's a pretty decent fighting force
when they disembark
and roll up on each other, it's
meant to be kind of like the vibes you got
during episode three, when Bo-Katan
met the Armor's group for the first time.
They were mistrustful
initially, also denoted here
what all the night owls
take their helmets off
because that's a big
no no for the armored group,
just showing you how different they are
with the armor chewing things out
by being her best guard
for Tamara together,
another symbol of Mandalore itself,
the forged hammer,
foreshadowing them, traveling to the great
forge, like the symbol of their people,
the heart of their culture,
as AX Wolves calls it,
when she says they'll have a banquet
to celebrate them coming.
The funny thing here, you remember,
is that the farmers group can't eat
without going to some different place
where they can actually
take their helmets off.
So the joke during the banquet
is that the only group that is eating
are the night owls themselves.
The rest of the Armor's
mandalorians are just kind
of standing there watching them eat.
When Greef
Karga gives Mando the boos from Khorasan,
I think that's meant to be a callback
to earlier Cain and Dr.
Pershing and what's currently
happening on course on.
They'll probably address
that during episode eight.
He also reveals
what's happened to ideal leaven and how
they've turned it into IG 12 in basically
like a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
Krang body for Grogu who like they go
for Krang with Grogu.
Why haven't you completed my new body?
Your body may feel some disorientation
when you revive and your new body
with him just riding around using IG
11 like a mech.
They mostly use the early part
of this episode with his body for comedy,
with Grogu
being able to communicate
by pressing buttons for simple words
like Yes
and No taika waititi's voice as IG 11
even though they're calling the Droid
IG 12.
Mostly it's meant to give Grogu
a huge weapons and defensive upgrade.
They don't really wind up using it
that much
during the episode
other than him breaking up the fight.
I think the idea is that in episode
eight, in future seasons he'll use it
in actual battle like Grogu
will actually wind up saving people.
But the main idea now is that
he's actually much more useful in battle.
Even though he is crazy powerful
in the force, he's still kind of like
a glass cannon, like he is incredibly
vulnerable as they run out.
He just keeps pressing the button.
Yes, yes, yes.
Killing a bunch of food
that he can get his hands on.
The shop owner that he keeps stealing
from is a Tor son.
We actually just saw a Tarzan Jedi
during the Star Wars acolyte trailer.
I just did a video for it,
so I do link in the description below.
That's one of the few new Star Wars series
coming next year that isn't connected
to what's happening in The Mandalorian
with all the Thrawn plot right now.
That's set during the High Republic.
So it's like a much earlier part, about
a hundred years before Phantom Menace.
During the feast, Bo-Katan gives them
another call to action speech reiterating
why they need to retake the Mandalore plan
and drop some big teasers.
When she says the bombings
from the Great Purge,
the tie bombers reawaken dormant species,
the radiation problems
prevent them from communicating
to or from the planet's surface.
That's why they can't radio their fleet
when they're attacked by the Mandalorian
Super commandos.
She wants to move the fleet to Mandalore
to retake the planet
or begin to retake the planet.
Revive the Great Forge using a small force
so they can start making new weapons.
Best armor again.
Mandalorian Weapons and armor Beskar
armor and weapons are so much better
than all the other armor in the galaxy.
That's exactly why Moff Gideon wants
to prevent them from retaking Mandalore.
Everyone agrees to go,
including the armor,
who was just talking to Bo-Katan
about her memories of the Great Forge
when she was much younger.
They don't reveal much about the Armor's
backstory.
Hopefully we'll get some teaser for that
in Episode eight, Bo-Katan
reveals how she originally
lost the Darksaber to Moff Gideon.
She surrendered it to him, believing
that the Empire would allow
the other Mandalorians to live
after they bombed the planet.
After the Night of a Thousand Tears,
she reveals that after
she surrendered the darksaber to him,
they either scattered them all
or killed any that tried to remain.
With a few exceptions,
like there are still a few mandalorians
obviously, that were living on the planet
that we find
when she starts talking about the ISB.
Moff Gideon Rose through the ISB,
he was a member of that group.
That's the same group we see on Andor
with the white uniforms, meaning that Moff
Gideon used to be running around
in a white uniform before he became a moff
And this is happening
right before the events of a new hope.
Before the events of the original trilogy.
The Armor explains that her group
survived the children of the Watch
because they were exiled to Concordia
because they were part of death watch
or they rose through
deathwatch before deathwatch,
basically scattered to the four winds.
And her group was a group
that sort of rose out of that.
But because they were on Concordia,
they were able to escape the empire
before they were able to arrive
after bombing the main mandalore planet.
This gets back to the whole idea
with the Mandalorian super commandos
in the module warriors that I was talking
about, this original death watch.
Like what happened to them
after the events of the Clone Wars,
they basically broke apart.
But you have to imagine that
when Darth Maul won the Darksaber
and took over Mandalore
a couple of the mandalorians
that were part of Deathwatch
swore allegiance to him
becoming the Maul Delorean's.
Then eventually those evolved
into the Imperial Super commandos
that are now working for Moff.
Gideon So all the talk of death
watches is meant to set up
all the Mandalorian super
commando stuff that you see with Moff
Gideon At the end of the episode,
Mando then apologizes to Bo-Katan
for believing all these lies about her.
He'd been taught all these wrong things
about what she did.
Oh, we thought you actually surrendered.
You were this week person and selfish.
When she responds by saying the darksaber
is all she has to unify her people,
that's a foreshadow for the mythos
or revealed this time
that all Mandalorian factions
take as a rallying cry
to come together and set aside
their differences.
I think we'll see more of that
in Episode eight.
I still think that Grogu will help them in
trying to calm it down.
Speaking to it through the force
of communicating to it through the force
the way that he did with the rancor
at the end of the book of Boba Fett,
and when Mando tells her that
he'll serve her until her song is written,
is basically saying until he either dies
or they're successfully retaking Mandalore
and defeat,
the Imperial Remnant is as close
as you can get in their culture
to a marriage proposal.
Basically, the way she reacts to a two,
it kind of seems
that they're trying to develop
this closer bond between the two of them.
There isn't much that they've done
with their relationship.
I don't think they're actually going
to get together or anything like that
any time soon.
But the three of them with Grogu,
who are as close
as you can get to a family subunit
within all the Mandalorians
space mom was space dad in the child.
Mando basically telling her
I would die to protect your smile.
During the episode.
You also probably notice
a bunch of new theme music
for a bunch of the different groups.
So when all the Mandalorians arrive
at the Planet Mandalore,
they play some special Mandalorian
theme music
they'll probably use in big battle scenes
that they have in the future.
Moff Gideon also gets a version
that too, was some special Moff Gideon
theme music when they're disembarking
on The Mandalorian Planet two.
It's meant to be a callback
to the previous episode
when they were fighting the pirates
dropping out of their ship
like their ships are designed
to be used by mandalorians with jetpacks,
where they drop them out like that
all the time.
Even past Vizsla, the others
start having their own versions of PTSD
flashbacks,
remembering the trauma of the Great Purge.
This scene of them
all working in formation,
dropping to the planet
is also meant to be a callback
to previously the season during season
one when they're all fighting together
as mandalorians.
We'll probably see a bunch more scenes
like this in future seasons in
obviously that Thrawn movie where they're
all fighting together on screen.
When Bo-Katan says they're standing above
where their ancient capital used to be.
That's the city scenario
that we saw during the Clone Wars.
The giant dome city is the same ruins
where she, Mando and Grogu were visiting
in the first few episodes.
They run into another faction
of Mandalorians
that have been living on the planet
since the Great Purge on a scale
barge just traveling around
like scavengers the whole time.
It's meant to look kind of like a classic
sailing ship mixed with Jabba Sail barge.
You might recognize this new mandalorian.
He's Charles Parnell.
He was just in Top Gun Maverick.
He's also done a bunch of other TV series
and movies.
The new faction takes them
the rest of the way to the Great Four
as this one AX moves.
Have that funny moment
where they're playing
the Mandalorian version of chess,
or like their version of Dujarric,
we're talking about the Star Wars
universe.
They argue over the rules pass.
Vizsla pulls his vibro blade
and they throw down
until Grogu stops them from fighting.
This is actually meant
to be a big metaphor to the idea
that Grogu was meant to be the nexus
of all these ideals that they believe in.
Like Mandalorian Jedi.
He's meant to be kind of
like the second coming of the TAA Vizsla,
the original Mandalorian Jedi.
So he's going to be a big part of unifying
all their different people
eventually,
probably including talking to the myth,
the saw through the force,
getting to chill out.
Also, when we talk about Grogu winning
over the myths or which they just tease,
wouldn't it be awesome Early theory here
if Grogu winds up
using the mythos to destroy Moff Gideon
based on Mandalore like the myth,
the story itself is so huge and powerful
it winds up helping the mandalorians
by crushing a lot of moff
Gideon resources and ships
very Thor Ragnarok like we might not
be enough to defeat you, but he is in
They pull the Thor ragnarok with her
only it's the myth this all this time
and because they want to push
through the Mandalorian
Super commandos Moff Gideon
the Pretorian Guard.
They see this giant creature.
It's not the
this or if you can believe that
even though it seems huge, it's
not the actual myth.
It's all because it doesn't have
those giant tusks of the mythos or on it.
It's just another major species
that was dormant.
They're driven into the caves not too far
from the same place Mando, Griego
and Bo-Katan went in the first few
episodes.
It's not the exact same place,
but it's close in.
Once they pass by the Great Forge,
the former
heart of the Mandalorian culture,
their attack by the Mandalorian Super
Commandos, the former Model Orient, now
serving Moff Gideon in the former members
of Deathwatch that the Armor was talking
about that broke off.
But this is why their helmets are beskar
versions
of traditional stormtrooper helmets
because Moff Gideon is basically
taking all the most powerful aspects
of the mandalorians like their best armor,
their technology, and using it to beef up
his imperial forces.
Really great battle scene.
You see the regular mandalorians
are better fighters overall, but
the super commandos have beskar armor,
making them way harder to kill.
But this is the whole reason
why Moff Gideon wanted Mandalore so bad.
He wanted their best guard
to use it for his army of super commandos.
And he's also trying to create
for sensitive clone troopers
now with best armor and weapons,
using the best
of all these different cultures,
as he says later,
every culture has something to offer.
But it would make his army
nearly invincible.
They chased them deeper
past the great force they find.
Moff Gideon.
The imperial base is constructed there.
That's because he set up shop there
the minute
after they pulled off the Great Purge.
So, like, it's been there for years.
That's why
they have so many imperial ships there.
It's also where the tie interceptor,
the tie bombers were that we saw destroyed
contains an ancestral home on collar Bala.
They were able to surprise
Mando and Bo-Katan so easily
because they had been stationed
so closely on Mandalore the planet.
They trapped Mando.
He finally whips out his flamethrower.
We haven't seen him use his flamethrower
that much this season,
and during season one
it was like a whole big thing.
Like he almost used his flamethrower
on every single episode in Moff, Gideon
enters using his own mandalorian
best go armor jetpack
wearing a small DeLorean helmet
with the Darth Maul horns on it.
Now, here's the thing.
A lot of big questions about Moff Gideon.
His past.
He didn't used to be a mandalorian
or even a small DeLorean.
He's more like a Mandalorian fanboy,
remember?
He was always part of the ISB.
He just wanted their beskar
weapons and technology.
Thanks to your planet's rich resources,
I have created
the next generation Dark Trooper suit.
And when he says he's created
the next generation of dark Trooper,
that's like the next step up
from what we saw during season two,
like another upgrade after that,
confirming all our theories
about how he escaped.
After episode five, the Beskar Alloy left
behind was from his dark troopers.
He confirms what was going on
with the Grogu cloning plot.
Like they're trying to clone
four sensitive, dark troopers now.
Every society has something to
offer the clones, the Jedi,
and even the Mandalorians.
Putting them in the best armor
would basically make them invincible.
But it's whole conversation
about combining the best attributes
of different cultures to make something
stronger is a callback to Doctor
Pershing's speech previously this season,
where he was talking about his cloning
technology, combining all the best aspects
of different types of people
to create something even better.
When he tells them to take Mando
to their debriefing room,
he probably intends on torturing him
For more information
about The Mandalorian forces
The New Republic
just to get more information
about what's going on.
Probably the same type of torture
that was used on Dr.
Pershing as well.
Sort of a dark mirror for that.
Like what were bad.
But The New Republic
also doing things that are just as bad.
Bo-Katan has another standoff with Moff
Gideon, referencing their previous history
before a new Hope
during the Great Purge with the Darksaber,
which he uses to cut a hole
through the blast door for them to escape,
which Moff.
Gideon then opens the other door
to try and kill them,
allowing Paz Vizsla to sacrifice himself
so the others can get away.
He goes out like a boss, like
he managed to take out
most of those regular Imperial
super commandos, even though they were in
best armor using his heavy blaster
until you see that it overheats
because he uses it so much
after which he just starts bum rushing
them, pushing them off of the cliff.
Then the three pretorian guard that Moff
Gideon requisitioned enter to kill him.
Like I said, they're wearing beskar armor.
They're the best trained
fighters in the galaxy,
using the best weapons
like the most hardcore possible fighters
you could possibly get next to the best
Mandalorian fighters.
You have to assume while
Project Necromancer was going
on, they were trying to clone the Emperor,
even though they were formerly
his Royal Guard, His own personal guard,
the Imperial Remnant, kept them active,
kept them training in After Paz
Vizsla Dies, R.I.P.,
everyone. Power went out for him.
They slammed the black and obviously now
pushing into the finale, the Mandalorians
have to figure out what to do next.
Now that they know what's really going on.
I think the idea is
they're going to try and continue
convincing the New Republic to help.
Like, No, no, you don't realize
Moff Gideon is trying to use our planet
to create this giant
fighting forces, this imperial remnant,
even though they don't totally know
everything about what's going on
with Grand Admiral Thrawn yet
the way that Rosario Dawson
talked about that when Ahsoka
was yelling about Grand Admiral Thrawn
during Mandalorian season two,
heading into the Ahsoka series,
she's one of the few people in the galaxy
that recognizes
the threat of Grand Admiral Thrawn,
that he is coming to retake the galaxy
from the New Republic.
So I don't think that all the Mandalorians
are going to figure out everything
that's going on with Thrawn
by the end of the season.
We might get a teaser for that,
but it might not be the Mandalorians
witnessing Thrawn
or learning anything about him
specifically.
It might just be on the Imperial Remnants
Shadow Council side of things
like, Oh, Grand Admiral Thrawn,
you finally arrived.
We've been talking about you
this whole time.
They'll probably be another big space
battle in episode eight two with Moff
Gideon the Imperial Remnant
or his forces on Mandalore.
If you spotted any other
big Easter eggs or references
during the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video,
there was so much stuff that happened
just right below in the comments.
My Episode 8 finale trailer video
we'll post in the next day.
There's also an extended Ahsoka trailer
with a whole bunch of extra footage
like Sabine using Ezra's lightsaber.
More grand Admiral Thrawn footage.
I'll do a video for that next in my Fall
Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 8 video we'll post
next Wednesday after they release it,
be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff
in trailers.
For all the new Star Wars series
that they announced on the description
below, everyone click here
for that Mandalorian Season 3 episode
8 Video.
I'll update the link
as soon as I post that and click here
for my Ahsoka trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone. Stay safe.
This is the way.